(upbeat music)
(thud)
- [Lina] She what?
- [Group] She punch.
- She elbow.
- [Group] She elbow.
- She kick.
- [Group] She kick.
- SheFighter.
- [Group] SheFighter.
(clapping)
(upbeat music)
(huffing)
- My name is Lina Khalifeh.
I'm the owner and founder of SheFighter,
the first self-defense studio
for women in the Middle East.
I teach a mix between taekwondo, boxing
and pure self-defense techniques.
We also empower women through
seminars and workshops,
like domestic violence, sexual harassment,
assault and also women empowerment.
(upbeat music)
I started in 2004
because one of my friends
got abused by her father and brothers.
I was really upset about her situation.
Because I have a
background in martial arts,
I decided to start giving lessons
for women in self-defense.
Domestic violence is a
high percent in Jordan,
in violence for women.
We have street harassment,
you don't see lots of girls
walking the street because of that.
(ethereal music)
SheFighter is safe
place for women to come
and talk about their issues because
all the other girls have been
mostly the same experience.
The physical training and mental training
both are really important.
So we start with talking to
the girls about their stories,
then we move to the training.
We have trained and empowered
more than 12,000 women.
(heavy bass music)
- Before I joined, I was facing
like, a lot of verbal harassment.
I felt so weak because I
couldn't do anything about it.
Since I joined, verbal
harassment is less now,
because I'm more confident now,
so when walking in street, that shows,
that reflects to other people.
- Most girls here, after the training,
they feel that they can
stand up for themselves.
It's about providing them
with the self-defense skills
to defend their rights and
to have a voice in society.